Падіння Берлінського муру - епохальний історичний момент,
що змінив життя не лише Німеччини, а й цілої Європи.
Я мешкаю тут неподалік і щоразу, коли я дивилася з вікна, бачила цей жахливий мур.
Це було так гнітюче - усвідомлювати, що далі муру не потрапиш.
Ми чекаємо вже 28 років.
Ми думали, цього ніколи не трапиться.
Ми щипали себе, чи справді усе це відбувається наяву, чи нам це не сниться.
Сподіваємося, так і залишиться.
Упродовж 28 років стіна відділяла капіталістичний Захід від комуністичного Сходу.
Керівництво НДР вирішило збудувати стіну 1961 року,
аби припинити масову втечу східних німців з НДР до ФРН.
Через Німеччину пролягла "залізна завіса".
Колючий дріт, блок-пости та системи сигналізації робили внутрішній німецький кордон неприступним.
Стіна пролягла не лише між НДР та ФРН, але й між сім'ями.
Упродовж 28 років східнонімецька спецслужба "штазі" утискала права людей.
Та навіть попри зведення муру понад 100 тисяч східних німців
ризикували життям, аби втекти на Захід.
Понад 600 осіб загинули під час спроби втечі.
Коли до влади у Радянському Союзі прийшов Михайло Горбачов, усе змінилося.
Започатковані ним реформи у Радянському Союзі -
гласність і перебудова - посилили тиск на керівництво НДР.
Політична та економічна невдоволеність призвела до масових протестів у Східній Німеччині.
Тепер або ніколи!
Приєднуйтеся!
Стіна має впасти!
І тоді сталося неймовірне.
Цього функціонера запитали, коли нарешті громадяни НДР зможуть вільно залишати країну.
І раптом він заявив:
Наскільки я знаю, з цього моменту. Негайно.
Новина миттєво поширилася у ЗМІ.
Десятки тисяч громадян НДР вирушили в напрямку Берлінського муру.
Прикордонникам довелося відкрити кордон 9 листопада 1989 року.
Ідеться про єдність і право, і свободу.
Нехай живе вільна німецька батьківщина!
Нехай живе вільна єдина Європа!
Менш як через рік - 3 жовтня 1990 року - Німеччина відсвяткувала своє історичне возз'єднання.
Через 30 років після цієї події
соціальні та економічні відмінності між західними та східними землями у ФРН все ще відчуваються.
Але падіння Берлінського муру довело, що епохальних змін можна досягти мирним шляхом.